who is a Zoroastrian you will see the
bumper sticker on the back of every
Zoroastrians car that says three things
good thoughts good words and good deeds
or actions and we like to think of this
slogan as really cutting across any
faith it we're not taking ownership of
thinking good thoughts speaking good
words and doing good deeds but it's a
nice way to summarize what a Zoroastrian
is taught and how the scripture says to
question to seek knowledge find the
truth and then be consistent about
speaking it and acting on it and the
framework behind all this is that we
have free will it's a very powerful and
it could be risky well where we allow
each person to make his or her own
decision as to what is right there are
guidelines and we are here in this world
to push against the not so good parts of
of the world and we are in one sense
you'll hear us as soldiers of good of
light of illumination of knowledge so we
can counteract the the evils in the
world so that's that's in a nutshell who
as the rest rien is and we we do it from
a prayer standpoint as well as acting
and practice